today the Federal Open Market Committee
decided to maintain the target range for
the federal funds rate at 1/4 to 1/2
percent the committee's baseline
expectations for economic activity the
labor market and inflation have not
changed much since December with
appropriate monetary policy we continue
to expect moderate economic growth
further labor market improvement and a
return of inflation to our 2 percent
objective in two to three years however
global economic and financial
developments continue to pose risks the
unemployment rate was four point nine
percent in the first two months of the
year about in line with the median of
FOMC participants estimates of its
longer-run normal level of note the
labor force participation rate has
turned up noticeably since the fall with
more people working or actively looking
for work as the prospects for finding
jobs have improved household spending is
expanding at a moderate rate supported
by continued job gains and increases in
inflation adjusted incomes in contrast
business investment has been weak in
part reflecting further reductions in
oil drilling as a result of low oil
prices net exports also remain soft as a
consequence of subdued foreign growth
and the earlier appreciation of the
dollar overall consumer price inflation
as measured by the price index for
personal consumption expenditures
stepped up to one and a quarter percent
over the 12 months ending in January the
committee expects inflation to rise to 2
percent over the next two to three years